in many ways
india's understand from the u.n security
vote does not necessarily speak so much
about india's concern over russia and
russia's military action against ukraine
that really speaks to india's own
strategic population
india's you know sticking with
non-alignment policy in many ways
it is frustrating from you know our
perspective right
it would not necessarily openly condemn
russia and then on the other hand it
would want to maintain its partnership
with the united states in terms of trade
in terms of
economic cooperation in terms of america
providing security guarantees in the
region
india is an american ally and is a very
important partner for america in the
indo-pacific region
india's primary concern is about his
rivalry with china and india's growing
concern about china's
rising influence in the not just in the
pacific region but also in the middle
east which is another area where india
has significant interest in
in terms of india's openly supporting
russia or helping russia avoid sanctions
i personally don't necessarily see that
it's going to be in india's interest
india probably does not want to do
things that would drive russia to
further support china which might risk
india's strategic security in the region
india and china has been having a
constant
border dispute
60 of india's arms purchase comes from
russia
probably india does not want to
openly condemn russia from that
perspective in case russia stopped
supplying india with you know arms
during the soviet time there is also a
historical alignment between russia and
india in the sense that india would look
up to
russia as the so-called soviet time big
brother
india is trying to balance its position
with its non-western
partners and then on the other hand also
trying to build or maintain a
relationship with western countries
they have for a long period of time have
been expressing their dissatisfaction
towards the western led or american net
global system